E aí
[Música]
o Olá Todos eu não sei se vocês eu peço
desculpa eu estou no meu telemóvel
portanto isso para procurar aqui pessoas
é mais complicado a ótimo eu não estou a
ver ninguém com baralho de cartas mas eu
vou espectar não atende aqui outra coisa
preparada mas
é o problema
se alguém que tenha um ótimo todos os
jornalistas não tem baralho de cartas aí
e o só que não seu nome tem um baralho
de cartas também Nordeste Nordeste a
Ótimo então podemos começar eu primeiro
falei perspectiva eu tenho aqui uma
coisa que eu acho que vai abalar um
bocadinho por trabalhar a nossa
perspectiva Eu tenho um baralho que é
que assim vocês alguma vez tinha visto
um horário assim
e na verdade na verdade é exatamente
isso não aguentei Isto É só uma questão
de perspectiva e eu já mudei eu já já
escrevi aqui criativa e a perspectiva é
porque na verdade eu tenho aqui algumas
cartas brancas mas e tem várias mas eu
tirar vocês veem já que a perspectiva de
estudo usa e que podemos ter
a outra vez últimos um baralho normal e
esse aparelho é normal foi o horário que
o Zé burraldo
e eu deixei isso tem grande por uma
razão já temos o jornal e o Norberto eu
vou pedir hoje final eu não nerds se
calhar posso não vou pedir ao jornal
Leonor que foi um acidente que me diga
uma coisa Qualquer que sintam que tenham
perdido na durante este tempo pandemia
confinamento um eu pedi um conceito
abstrato paciência paciência Então vou
escrever paciência e jogo não
o tempo de Tóquio
a mulher tempo é isso
o Zap
o tempo próprio de escrever tempo só
para ficar a
o livro fiz outra pessoa qualquer não
vou esquecer vai ser uma pessoa renda
meu vou andar por aqui por aqui por aqui
e eu estou a ver aqui a Susana Martins
Susana Martins
o importa se partilhar connosco uma
coisa qualquer
o que tenha perdido
Oi Ana Martins desapareceu
bom então vou escolher outra pessoa pode
ser Adriana Abreu é que eu não tenho
muito tempo
Oi pode falar
a viagem a possibilidade de viajar
o ok então podemos dizer concorda comigo
se eu disser Liberdade radares em
E aí
e enquanto isso eu vou pedir que vão a
vosso baralho e tirei os 4 anos todas as
pessoas têm um baralho e Quiz 4 anos a
tua aqui a ver mais pessoas que muralhas
Julho e faltar e Ótimo ótimo ótimo a
e três quatro horas porque eu acredito
que vocês não tenham estas cartas assim
branquinhas bonitinhos como eu tenho mas
também não tem importância nenhuma
Oi e a partir deste momento eu vou pedir
até por isso mais para baixo eu vou
pedir para vocês prestem atenção que eu
estou a fazer e que faça exatamente o
que eu estou a fazer eu vou só tirar o
montinho aqui de cartas lá um município
pequeno não precisa de ser muito grande
se não é
quem sabe ter uma duas três quatro cinco
seis sete oito nove dez onze doze treze
quatorze quinze dezesseis Ok podem pegar
todas as cartas porque eu tirei
e assim vamos ficar todos com tirando
usados Peguei mais as cartas então no
Redondo é perfeito
E aí
e eu vou por isso mais não temos todos
eu acho que sim eu vou tentar no andar
muito rápido porque eu também não
consigo ver a todos mas eu quero que
faça exatamente o que eu fizer a partir
de agora
a este monte não tem que fazer este
leque mas este mundo
e eu quero pedir os vossos olhos virados
para cima tem um presentão não tem que
ser exatamente está aqui mas representam
aquilo que você sente que perderam estes
tempos
o rolinho xuxando e põe aqui nestes
tempos de todo internacionais e
Com certeza absoluta o que ver se a
tarde quase toda a gente eu acho que sim
já está toda a gente pode e pode molhar
e nem preciso de fazer analogia nenhuma
porque ao vivo todos nós sentimos
baralhados desde que isso começou até
agora do pelo menos falo por mim mas eu
perdi uma coisa e por que exatamente tem
matemática durante bastantes anos da
minha vida que é não pode molhar assim
se não conseguir a verdade outra forma
igual quando temos um problema grande
com bem dividir em problemas mais
pequenas são podemos pegar em celular
vamos assim para o lado pode ser 10
cartas uma duas três quatro cinco seis
sete oito nove dez
Ah e Assim ficamos com problemas mais
reduzidos não é mais presiden temos
números mas em termos para Cidade nós
vamos ter que dar a volta ao dele vamos
ter mergulhar fundo já eu vou perguntar
Norbert ou pode ser Adriana Adriana
Adriana qual é que damos a volta
e damos a volta o que tem 10
É este aqui ou a este aqui é isso é o
que tem 10 é o primeiro separou quem das
cartas estudamos a volta eu peço que
faça o mesmo
a linha volta assim e agora
a volta virar uma quem virá ao contrário
se viram ao contrário virei um deles ao
contrário e agora eu ia fazer isso uma
maneira mas se calhar faz assim é mais
fácil Vamos olhar isso tudo olha por uma
carta do mundo só para ser mais fácil
outra carta de longe uma carta de
Londres outra carta do monte e assim
fica tudo embaralhado de certeza
absoluta
bom e mal começamos a fazer isso já
vemos que não está a resultar mas já
vemos que não pago toda resultado então
liberamos da nós pegamos um dois três
quatro
se não tiverem mesa de fazer na cama mas
eu não tiver em qualquer coisa que tenha
uma coisa lá e continuamos E à medida
que continuamos vemos que isto não tá
não vai a lado nenhum eu acredito que
todos nós temos sentido assim um pouco
podem ajeitar as duas pontinhas todos
quiserem pra ficar mais direitinho a
acredito que todos os tinha me sentido
assim um pouco que atacamos os problemas
de várias formas não sabemos muito bem
como lidar com a realidade como ela se
encontra atualmente estamos este
cruzamento é preto branco para o ímpar
sim ou não é 5050 estamos aqui eu vou
perguntar o jornal talvez jornal para
limpa
isso é tudo o que disseram que o sanpaku
a
e pega nos vossos mundos par dois e
junto e por 4
e pega nos vossos mundos impor e juntos
a e agora parece que estamos estamos a
chegar a algum lado mas não temos aquela
nenhum Mas vamos ter que dar a volta o
problema o que é o tal qual é que foi ao
contrário pode ser Adriana outra vez que
está aqui viramos ao contrário esse esse
estão vocês podem tirar o vosso ao
contrário também viram ao contrário e
agora vou fazer isso sem aquilo que é
chamado janela aqui lá e acham que não
conseguem fazer isso é muito simples oi
eu gosto de indicador no centro das
cartas rodam assim e que os vossos
lugares vamos fazer só para cima Battery
não precisa fazer nada e linhas cartas
uma no meio das outras E deixamos assim
eu não preciso levantar isso pode juntar
tudo junto tudo
bom E como eu fiz o meu ouviu nós
fazemos estudo e às vezes o que nos
falta mesmo é só acreditarmos que já lá
chegamos e que e conseguimos alterar
alguma coisa porque e temos uma
perspectiva que nos permitia ver as
coisas de um ângulo mais favorável
porque se vamos nessa perspectiva a
Conseguimos ver tudo aquilo estava agora
já está organizado mas
o caso únicas coisas que saem
a perspectiva
o livro perspectiva a paciência a
liberdade e o tempo eu convido saber
convosco também o que é que aconteceu
podem abrir os meus ácidos para cima
uma das cidades para cima únicas coisas
tudo bem sim e vocês devem achar vocês
devem achar também aconteceu
o tempo passou era só o Adriano Estação
desligado certinho só usar meu ficaram
os ossos e um 10 10 que é área de
engrenagem Não Faz Mal Às vezes acontece
mas vocês podem achar que isto Só
resulta porque eu tenho algum tipo de
capacidade de superior e visão iluminada
mas eu gostava de vos mostrar uma coisa
mais uma vez e para acabar quando
comecei que é um
É nós na verdade quando achamos que
somos muito diferentes uns dos outros
acabamos por ser todos iguais era isso
que eu queria mostrar até a próxima foi
um prazer Ah eu tenho uma coisa
importante para fazer isso pode ser um
bocadinho mas eu gostava de vos pedir eu
tenho aqui ir para me seguirem no no
Instagram eu tenho aqui o meu Instagram
eu não sei se você consegue ler Miguel
pontos diferentes calhar É sim já tá
melhor que Miguel. Fronteiro fizerem ao
fazer mal uma pergunta ou perguntar
alguma coisa sejam à vontade sobre o que
se passou aqui ao sobre outra coisa
Qualquer eu acho que estaria disponível
qualquer das formas perna uma longa
muito sei que vírgulas olha só o que foi
um prazer e até a próxima
E aí
[Música]